commençons par le commencement
il était une fois un cinéaste et sa
vedette venu nous offrir pour les fêtes
un conte de fées peau d'âne dans les
demoiselles ou dans les paras beach
amour dans l'eau là un beau film était
disons d des rêves réaliste de l'emprise
paradoxe l'âge aidant poda pour passer
carrément dans le conte de fées
absolue pourquoi mais c'est un conte de
fées réaliste d'âge les prises sur un
pied réaliste simplement parce que pour
que vous croyez un prince charmant une
princesse à lille fait un roi une reine
il faut que ce soit des gens comme vous
et moi c'est à dire qu'ils ont des
réactions humaines qu'ils soient des
gens qui réagissent dans le quotidien
comme nous réagissons si ce sont des
personnages abstrait vous n'y croyez pas
ça ne vous intéresse pas et puis ils
seront quotidiens puis ils sont vrais
plus le merveilleux intervenant au
milieu du réalisme sera étonnant et je
pense que c'était la seule façon de
raconter un conte de fées donc c'est
aussi un film réaliste et pourquoi pas
d'un moule à vivre dans votre jeunesse
j'ai tout lu tous les comptes quels
qu'ils soient dans ma jeunesse j'adorais
ça je trouvais je ne sais pas bon il ya
beaucoup d'enfants qui aime qui n'aime
pas tellement qu'ils aiment la réalité
mais en même temps tout était possible
moi je parlais à mon crayon mon mouchoir
amont plumier je veux dire j'avais du
dialogue avec tout le monde je n'étais
pas du tout emprunté pour quoi que ce
soit
parce que ça me paraissait tout à fait
normal que les choses parlent
d'eux-mêmes que la rose parle dans le
film on m'avait dit qu'elle l'éleveur
avait un langage dont on peut très bien
parlé avec une rose si on en a envie il
n'y avait pas de frontières pour moi et
j'ai lu tous ses comptes je les aimais
beaucoup quand je les ai relu adulte
j'ai pensé qu'il y avait là deux films
vraiment il y avait un film pour adultes
qu'un film pour les enfants ce qui est
très rare de trouver un sujet qui soit
passionnant pour tous ce qu'il y a un
compte qui est comme ça une histoire
complètement ferrer qu'une princesse le
père amoureux de sa fille la princesse
qui s'amène à la forêt la peau d'âne
toute la deuxième partie dans le dans la
forêt dans la ferme côté peau d'âne
souillon le prince charmant qui est une
chose purement ferry comme ça un compte
au premier degré mais il y a comme donc
beaucoup de contes de fées de même que
dans les les histoires de la comtesse de
ségur et dans les contes de ma mère la
mère doit il y a quelque chose d'un peu
plus mystérieux d'un peu plus subtil que
les enfants ne voient pas je ne sais pas
si ça a été fait je sais pas si on peut
dire que ç'a vraiment été écrit dans ce
sens là mais il y a évidemment quand on
pense à quand même l'histoire d'amour du
bureau avec sa fille qui est l'histoire
vraiment d'une passion car c'est quand
même un droit qui s'offre in pour sa
fille cet exo 1000 fassi aussi un enfant
n'y aura pas de l'histoire il vous dira
c'est une princesse qui est amoureuse de
son papa mais toutes les petites filles
quand elles sont petites veulent épouser
leur part pas dont il n'y a rien de mal
à ça et les grandes personnes tous
verront une chose plus trouble mais
c'est vrai que je pense que les enfants
ne sont pas pervers et que les enfants
ne sont pas jetés en ce qui concerne non
pas de problème que c'est plus tard que
les problèmes viennent enfin quand on
les sait les adultes qui les
conditionnent vraiment oui que ce sont
les frustrations et mais les choses
comme ça qui deviennent on leur tape sur
les mains où ils se disent il ya quelque
chose d'un peu mieux
un peu plus tard et ils n'en parlent
plus ils finissent par y penser je crois
qu'il vaut mieux montrer les choses pour
que les enfants soient complètement
libéré nous ferons ce lieu inter
allah
fumant la pipe en cachette
nous gagnerons de pâtisseries
nous fait
ce retour
ce qui fait le privilège d'un tournage
comme celui de peau d'âne c'est
justement de voir comme chacun peut
retrouver son enfance et retrouver
décider de son enfance à propos de deux
choses un peu fantastique c'est toujours
le retour à jeunesse perdue un peu pas
du tout pas et c'est sans nostalgie
c'est simplement que préoccupé par le
quotidien par vos impôts par son
problème par les maladies par tous ceux
qui pressent dans la vie vous ne pensez
plus à votre enfance jamais or souvent
si les adultes correspondait aux enfants
qui l'ont été ce soit des adultes assez
intéressants mais ils ont oublié
complètement ils font pas assez le petit
retour sur soi qui permettrait il
justement de retrouver une conviction de
force quelque chose de très intéressant
on a on a ses torts
elle peut regarder en arrière de temps
en temps pour avoir un futur meilleur
[Musique]